that it this movie messed me up thank
you yeah I'm so we're so happy that like
you like it yeah that's good oh shoot
breathless right I bet I bet my are
foodies I bet my producer Seth
grahame-smith that if we got fresh
fronts we don't see by mikio sir yeah we
had I get weird inside joke where I was
like oh when you retire South like
you're just gonna like be bankrupt and
you're just gonna drive a kisser into
his neck you know what I'll buy you all
the Kia Sorento's like if this gets
fresh and run smooth okay you're done
all right
so without thinking about it as a
warm-up question what's the stupidest
thing that you are scared of by a hotel
like you know like long hotel hallways
oh good one uh Coyotes stupid I'm scare
when I'm in the shower and I get water
my eyes yeah I bet split second ocean
the devil just came in here or something
confessional I am scared of bare feet on
wet grass Oh yours is gross yeah yeah
yeah I understand
oh my I have something similar to that
it's like you know the sound like when
people are in snow and they like Stefan
the snow but it's it's not like smooth
so it's like crunches are that you I
love that I hate that so now look to
your left and say who should play that
person in the next movie later and chose
later
Jordan Peele okay oh yeah I'll do it
I like that I like that Oh oh my gosh
what's his name I'm Jordan
that's okay all good choices I think
okay I love it
Jordan whew I do like Jordan Peele as
that really due to voice detective
they'd be cool it'd be a good dramatic
actor yeah we said we saw a little bit
of that earlier this year you did get it
that's funny so I want to play like a
super special clown edition of would you
rather okay okay very serious questions
and your answers are gonna shape the
rest of your life okay would you rather
be possessed or be on fire Wyatt I don't
have to experience it Oh smart how long
would you be on fire for like what do
you die or would you isn't it like
unlimited fire rages I'm burning for
love lemonade fire when you're burning
for the rest of eternity weld it will do
well if I'm possessed away I do what
could I come out of it
No so I possess forever ever ever yeah I
guess I get out possessed like where
you're watching from like a distance oh
right demon eye I would say I would say
teenis your moment possess possess me
I'd be on fire you know I don't want
anybody inside of me okay
amen to that listen on fire hunter
percentage idea would you rather be
bleeding or puking um bleeding depends
how much I'm bleeding
puking for how long um I'm gonna say
bleeding profusely from
your abdomen okay okay got it for 47
minutes dot it okay okay
definitely PU then I'm hungry I feel
like you're leaning towards puke now
yeah I feel better and how long are you
puking for no but that's the point
oh I'm getting the wrap now okay so
that's the last one okay would you
rather eat a booger pizza or kiss
Pennywise in the mouth kiss penny wise
penny was kind of cute you know I got
that she got the red children breath oh
yeah there's a problem for me oh yeah
what's the dumbest thing that gives you
the creeps my closet door oh just in
general yeah
earlier Oh deep that's deep as hell
the scotchgard attended me the creeps
it's a good choice I had I had some
nightmares I'm not gonna lie when I want
to yeah
the dumbest thing yeah dumb thing okay
besides like falling to a pool with a
tarp over it I think is genuine real
fear not bananas because that's also
nuts
young pigeons that's he he was afraid of
pigeons did you yes yes that's fair
scarab beetles sable they go in your
hair I mean maybe they like a tiny the
hair like I've never had that you're
right bro that is pretty stupid okay now
I would like for you to look to your
right and tell me who will play that
character in part two you're gonna pop
it over forget but oh okay so I'm going
for Jack EULA Jake Gyllenhaal the
soulful brown eyes
my turn yep okay for who Jeremy for me
no this is Toby McGuire but he just told
me not to so what I like that one
can we move our good choice Aiden oh my
Adams or Jessica Chastain I love that
answer I would like to play a special
dancing clown edition what would you
rather yeah okay so the course of this
game is gonna change your life I promise
you okay would you rather be possessed
or be on fire fire you possess fire fire
fire fire riling that a lot goes wrong
way would you rather be bleeding or
puking puking bleeding no you guys what
you owe my puke I like the projectile
vomited gross and to answer your
question how much are you bleeding I'm
in one day you're bleeding approximately
you're just bleeding profusely out of
your abdomen for like 45 minutes
that's not physically possible but
cuz I hurt yes and I don't know if I was
like how long such as yeah you make it
is the boots - almost puke because I
don't like okay literally you neither I
know and the last one cuz I have to get
out of here would you rather eat a
booger pizza or kiss Pennywise on the
mouth
[Laughter]
[Music]